So the, these three conditions that Jared has come up with
about whether it's available, whether it hasn't been requested by somebody else
and the one that we had before concerning age correspond to three conjuncts.
You know, three, three possibilities that all must hold. And
as we talked about a minute ago we could have three separate preconditions, or
we could have one precondition with three, with, with two ands separating
the three parts of it. The other thing to note in the expression of it is.
We've use some new operation names, in expressing it.
So we said, is available. Now, is available is not one that came
out of the process of building the [UNKNOWN] class diagram. But that's okay.
It's like. Breaking the writing of a a method into, into pieces and
calling other methods along the way. Okay it's, it's just divide and
conquer. So, we're going to assume we can invent the names of these convenient
operations. And, that simplifies the, not only the writing here, but
the reading as well, if we're trying to show the requirements to the customer.